[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning it's
time to bring you some of the stories we
call talk at the table and tony is in
pole petition so they're all positions
there have long been questions about
whether social media really does
anything
for social movements or it just feels
good well there is a new study out this
morning its first on cbs this morning
that suggests that
social media conversations did in fact
help pave the way
for real life reforms during the black
lives matter protest last summer so the
study out this morning
finds a correlation between the two the
number of police reform measures
considered in each state
and the amount of social media activity
about social justice so it's according
to an analysis by a group called
marathon strategies
the names of victims including george
floyd and brianna taylor were
shared more than 48 million times across
social media between mid-may and
september of last year
and during that same time state
lawmakers across the u.s
considered or proposed more than 400
reform measures to fix policing now the
study cautions that it cannot for sure
make a causal connection between the two
however listen to this
among the six states in washington d.c
that surpassed
one million mentions on social media
state legislatures considered an
average of 20 police reform measures in
the 17 states with fewer than a hundred
thousand measure
mentions legislative bodies considered
only an average of
two reform measures and many considered
none
at all so there could in fact be it
suggests there may be a connection
something to retweeting things it's not
just pressing a button you could be
adding to uh
to an actual movement that makes sense
to me
i get that i get it